education is the Cornerstone of
connection but for young kids
communicating can be tough as they're
learning their words and that's where
sign language comes in believe it or not
children as young as six months old can
learn it Candace Charles has been
learning it as well she's live this
morning with One Day Care Center's
effort to expand language Candace good
morning good morning Dad good morning
folks yes I have been seeing the Kids In
Action they've kind of been showing me
some of the moves so take a look at your
screen right now here are some of the
things they've been showing me this one
do you know what that means and this one
you know what this one means well these
are two gestures as I said two of many
really the kids have been learning as
young as six months old at The Learning
Experience Center in Rhodes ranch now
this is something that they've been
doing as part of their American Sign
Language curriculum students from six
months to five years old learn one or
more signs at least once a month and the
teacher repeats them until the students
pick it up and as I mentioned they
really do research has shown that for
young children's sign language can
foster communication skills motor skills
and even enable them to speak earlier
and have larger vocabularies
if and social emotional development
because they can Bond more because they
know what we're talking about they have
access to the identity of things in the
world
now your baby using ASL also reduces
frustration Tantrums which you know is
great for everyone and increases
self-esteem also making it easier for
other people to be around them and
families don't necessarily need to
attend a course to learn you can get a
picture book with the signs and enroll
your child to school with the program in
place you know want to learn more about
the learning experience daycare center
in Rhodes ranch we'll get the full
details at new and I'm going to show you
really quickly what these mean
that means eat
this means all done which I'm gonna go
get them all done
guys